bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette autre
édition d' espace autochtones en direct
je m'appelle l'adm arrivons nous allons
passer les prochaines minutes ensemble
avec mes deux invités eric cardinal
monsieur cardinal bonjour alors qu'ils
et vous monsieur cardinal rapidement là
moi je suis consultant expert de la c1
avec les communautés autochtones
vous savez à la fois avec les
communautés autochtones ou avec des
entreprises ou organisations qui veulent
de bonnes relations
parfait ça met la table et cindy were de
chroniqueuse à espace autochtone mais
vous êtes aussi doctorante vous
travaillez fort en ce moment et vous
êtes à l'université du québec en
abitibi-témiscamingue etc
qu'est ce que vous y faites je charge de
co et j'ai fait mes recherches sur la
sur représentation des femmes
autochtones dans le milieu carcéral
voilà presque oui bon aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas notre sujet mais quand même on
n'est pas loin de là bon parce qu'on
parle de la couverture médiatique sur
les enjeux autochtones et on parle
beaucoup des femmes autochtones au nord
la couverture médiatique d'ailleurs
particulièrement depuis les derniers
mois avec les commission denquête que ce
soit l'anfa dalle enquête nationale sur
des femmes autochtones assassinées ou
disparues ou encore la commission vient
au québec
avant d'aller plus loin cindy vous avez
écrit une chronique cette semaine
exactement sur ce sujet-là de la
couverture médiatique alors ça serait le
fun de revenir dessus vous l'avez
intitulé les autochtones dans les médias
être invisible ou problématiques jassem
mais la table etes-vous invisible
parfois elles parfois problématique
en fait c'est ça c'est mon constat
personnel mais je me rends compte quand
j'entends avec d'autres personnes qui
sont autochtone surtout c'est partager
comme opinion on les soins visimmo
problématique dans les médias je me suis
posé la question pourquoi pourquoi ces
persistants comme ça parce que comme je
l'écris dans ma chronique
moi je la première fois j'ai observé ça
c'était l'heure de la crise d'oka
j'étais un peu plus jeune j'avais jamais
été avant la crise d'oka exposés à une
panoplie de préjugés et de stéréotypes
ou de constat que les jeunes partagé que
j'étais comme mes connaissances puis
j'avais pas d'où ça sort nu et puis ss
c'est sûr c'était négatif et ça faisait
mal et tout dernièrement on parlait de
commission vient ben mes filles j'ai
deux filles puis c'est elle qui ont été
exposés à ce genre de traitement
médiatique lui faire face à des préjugés
et des stéréotypes mais beaucoup de
questions pourquoi pourquoi pied on
s'est mis à jaser depuis mon consisté
comme savaient pas beaucoup évolué a
nantes la crise d'oka et le traitement
médiatique et effet ce tour dénonciation
des femmes l'accusent de val d'or alors
si je comprends bien il ya eu aucune
curiosité sur la réalité de ces femmes
là on ne s'intéressait pas à leur sort
et on ne voulez pas en savoir plus
et alors quoi ces nouvelles a été
relégué en 15e pages d'un journal par
exemple
ben en fait moi les premiers constats
que j'ai fait par rapport aux journaux
dans les médias sociaux
il ya eu une mini vague de sympathie un
les gens ont été outrés dans un premier
temps
j'espère après on s'est mis à
décortiquer le pourquoi
c'est devenu négatif c'est devenu
l'épicé à quelque part va envoyer même
que c'était probablement la faute de ces
femmes le qui avait elle-même chercher
ce problème n'ont donc fait que ça a
servi encore un peu la sympathique un
piano dans les médias elle ne dure pas
pieds elle est très timide
et puis entre je n'en parlais tantôt il
ya eu des recherches là dessus puis ça
confirme un peu mon constat personnel
oui oui monsieur cardinal vous avez
présenté à mémoire justement à la
commission vient à propos du rôle des
médias dans l es vraiment la couverture
journalistique concernant les enjeux les
problématiques autochtone aussi les
belles réalisations autochtones
de quoi vous parlez dans votre mémoire
en fait je parlais oublier
journalistique pour souligner une chose
dont on sait tous qu'on s'en rend compte
que les médias ont une influence dans
l'opinion publique et que parfois
certains journalistes certains médias
vont écrire avec des billets différents
billets pour à l'égard de la couverture
des autochtones en retz où elle
deviendra mais il ya différents billets
bien bien spécifiques mais moi mon but à
la commission vient c'est peut-être de
démontrer l'importance de l' influence
des médias et du traitement des médias à
l'égard des autochtones dans les
services publics par c'est elle c'est le
sujet de la commission ambition des
travaux de la commission donc et moi
j'ai travaillé pour le ministre affronte
octobre donc moi en fait
moi je suis je suis un jules et j'ai
étudié en droit chemin spécialisé un
spécialiste du droit autochtone
l'enseignant droits des autochtones
mais depuis plusieurs années ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la question des
communications et des relations
publiques avec les autochtones notamment
dans la perspective sûrement des
services publics de l'état
je me suis rendu compte de sûr quand je
travaillais au cabinet du ministre des
affaires autochtones le ministre
commence sa journée
comment en lisant les revues de presse
donc la première chose qu'il fait et
savoir orienter toute sa journée de
travail si ce qu'il vaut lire ces
l'immédiat c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on
voit dans les journaux ou dans les
médias le matin même et puis c'est la
même chose pour les membres de son
cabinet les fonctionnaire au ministère
donc c'est là une influence très
importante
puis on parlais tantôt de du traitement
journalistique et le l'idée même des
journalistes qui pensent bien traités ou
qui d'une bonne intention par l'histoire
de la crise de bâle dans des femmes
demandant où des sujets plus sociaux
comme récemment on parle d'une carcéral
où on va parler on va traiter la
situation
au nunavik par exemple pauvreté donc les
mêmes les médias ou les journalistes qui
pensent traiter un sujet en étant très
progressiste très ouvert où même et dans
la cause autochtone va avoir un effet
pervers
parce que on lit souvent dans les médias
mais quand on est deux problématiques on
voit le sait où il va y avoir une
interprétation comme si c'était
d'enfants d'une certaine façon de leur
faute mais pourquoi tu dis ça sans
préjuger déjà en partant mais il ya
effectivement des préjugés
il ya beaucoup de méconnaissance le
premier billet ce qui joue beaucoup
c'est la méconnaissance des cultures des
réalités des groupes autochtones des
médias et des journalistes non
autochtone problématique l'autre leur
billet c'est ce que j'appelle la mine la
différence culturelle
en fait le fait qu'un journaliste qui
tenait un enjeu autochtone ne voit pas
que c'est un élément d'une dimension de
interculturel qui devait l'amener à
traiter le sujet différemment qu'il
quitterait le même sujet mais à l'égard
d'un dans une communauté non autochtone
le problème c'est qu'on va traiter pas
réussir qu'une sensibilité
oui mais de comprendre que l'enjeu par
exemple des violences dans une
communauté mais dans une communauté
inuit par exemple c'est pas la même ça
devrait pas être traités de la même
façon qu'un pratiques de violence dans
dans cette communauté non autochtone
dans son village quelqu'un oui cette
matière de perspectives la qui doit être
mise de l'avant et à écrire ou de faire
son reportage
oui puis ça des celliers avec une
histoire qui tellement différente de
celle des québécois et des canadiens qui
étaient là méconnus ou si on n'en tient
pas compte donc remise en contexte la
mise en contexte même pour la
préparation du journaliste c'est ce que
je relevais la commission et les c'est
qu'un journaliste vous aller couvrir une
situation par exemple à l'international
en afrique va se préparer en est là
justement cherché cette information là
le contexte historique
le contexte culturel mais quand on va te
traiter un événement que ce soit à
manawan par exemple chez les attikameks
ou chez une moto neuvic
le même journaliste ne prend pas on ne
fait pas le même et fentes souvent
pourquoi
oui parce que c'est une question de
temps aussi parce qu'on lui demande de
witte rapidement fournir son article ou
alors parce que littéraire on veut se
simplifier la vie je sais pas je vous
pose la question mais c'est peut-être
plusieurs réponses
une des réponses que moi j'ai observé
c'est ce que j'appelle la différence
culturelle ou le port un journaliste
québécois
elle était un sujet dans une communauté
autochtone c'est traiter d'une situation
québécoise une problématique québécois
ans pour lui c'est pour elle ça demeure
des québécois donc cette distinction
l'offre culturelle nationale mais elle
n'est pas aussi tranchée
oui oui des fois je me demande aussi
maintenant entre la crise d'oka est
maintenant là comme si on vient le sait
moins mais de repères oui les gens à
l'époque comme moi qui rentrait alors
aux études postsecondaires à cette
époque-là de la crise d'oka est
aujourd'hui travail c'est les
professionnels de les gens qui ont été
un peu fort mais avec ce qui a été
véhiculé dans les médias c'est la crise
donc donc les préjugés et stéréotypes
autochtone qu'on a tous entendu c'est
intégrer ce prix prouver dans les études
les jeunes
il ya eu un texte beaucoup ce qu'ils
entendent dans les médias donc je me
demande c'est que pas il répond une
piste là dans ce sens que ces gens là
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont journalistes qui
sont lecteur de nouvelles ou en coop
breizh qui travaillent dans les médias
est ce qu'ils se sont pas un peu fait
formé avec ce qui a été dit et entendu
au moment de la crise grecque a alors je
vais en profiter tout de suite pour
préciser que si vous avez des questions
pour nos deux invités alors on a mis la
table maintenant vous avez de quoi il
est question mais si vous avez des
questions précises à leur poser ne vous
gênez pas fait le immédiatement parce
que vous allez voir leur tombe vite et
donc les questions ne devraient pas
arriver à la toute fin de l'émission on
aura le temps d'y répondre
moi j'en ai une est ce que il faut être
autochtone pour parler des enjeux
autochtones parler de la réalité
autochtone et là je me suis un petit peu
je vais me cacher
je ne suis pas autochtone et pourtant je
travaillais espace autochtone mais est
ce qu'on devrait être autochtones parce
que c'est un peu le cas si be seen des
jeans les journalistes sont des
autochtones est ce que c'est une bonne
idée mais moi je prends ça évidemment
évidemment mais pas que ça parce qu'il
ya des gens qui sont très très
observateur qui ont été grêlée milieu je
pense maintenant à monsieur serge
bouchard kéké qui fait mystères et oui
longtemps et il n'est pas plus crédible
annonçant sa moi quelqu'un monsieur
bouchard parle poésie nous par exemple
mais oui je pense que ce serait une
bonne pratique parce que comme je
l'écris dans ma chronique
les jeunes sont en nombre démographique
est assez élevé ces gens là et c'est
duke se spécialise donc j'ose espérer
que la couleur médiatique va changer
parce que ces jeunes là qui sont nos
futurs professionnels dans les médias
connaissent la réalité connaissent
l'histoire exemple de billets la culture
elle faisait référence
avec ce oui je pense ça peut aider mais
ccpo spray vaste ou non plus le je pense
mais chez virgin al oui ben c'est sûr
que ça aide
c'est un élément qui fait que la
couverture médiatique d'ailleurs
s'améliore parce qu'il y en a de plus en
plus de journalistes autochtone puis on
voit c'est sûr que ça fait une
différence
mais il ne faut pas pas uniquement
autochtone parce que des journalistes
qui couvrent tous les biens les sujets
autochtone qui ne sont pas toc toc oui
c'est une question maintenant de bien
comprendre le sujet le contexte points
et de réaliser que les autochtones forme
des nations distingue tous et bon boulot
mais on dit autochtone mais il faudrait
y aller de façon plus précise aussi les
premières nations les inuits et puis si
on parle de mes disques d'associer autre
chose un autre enjeu oui oui qui amène
beaucoup de temps pelez puis elle
alimente complexité aussi parce que un
journaliste on vous le disiez tantôt
important pour paypal et son reportage
doit aller faire les entrevues et encore
on l'envoie son cas où on ne l'envoie
pas est ce que les journalistes vont
beaucoup dans les communautés maintenant
également comment sont ils accueillis
dans les communautés où comment se
présente-t-il dans les communautés il ya
aussi tous ces enjeux là mais je pense
qu'à une question de région puis ça je
dois vraiment juste mon expérience
personnelle le show qu'une recherche là
dessus j'ai vu que comme si on vient et
parce que j'enseigne à lui 4 chaque
événement est couvert jusqu'à que j'ai
commencé à être une cause ici à
radio-canada abitibi m'ont approché
connaître tes jeux réseau super
intéressant je trouve que on est comme
plus intéressé plus impliquée dans les
enjeux autochtones entrait en région
deux autres coups de l'abitibi c'est le
côté jeune autre exemple du contrat mais
bref ça doit dépendre un peu de
de quoi on parle finalement mais je ne
sais pas des fois j'ai l'impression dans
les grands centres urbains c'est un peu
noyé puisque on en retient c'est
l'itinérance les problèmes de violence
les problèmes qui conseil de bande
le négatif finalement alors tout ce qui
est un problème donc toutes les belles
réalisations des autochtones
sont mises de côté on ne fait pas
ressortir vous allez aussi cette
impression là toujours mais en fait il
ya pas longtemps j'ai un exemple sur
facebook facebook il ya une dame qui
partageaient un non autochtone
il y avait un événement de hockey de
ballon balai de grande importance dans
la région d'abitibi par route je me suis
encore là dans un petit village et cette
dame lorsqu'elle mettait en lumière
c'est que l'organisation avait été top
numéro un c'est pikogan qui avait pris
tout en charge et aucune couverture
médiatique
pourtant tout s'était super bien déroulé
et puis c'était vraiment un événement
qui avait favorisé les liant totaux lol
non autochtone si on parle de
réconciliation beaucoup dans la région
de val-d'or puisqu'à mettait en lumière
ses 87 dommage bien comprenait pas d'un
fonds à s'interroger pourquoi réfléchi
une balle dehors peut-être to where we
say say say média que moi j'ai
accompagné l'équipe du québec aux jeux
autochtones de l'amérique du nord puis
c'était c'est un défi d'intéresser les
médias parce qu'il n'y avait pas si
c'est la journée où on avait un élément
controversé ballon l'utiliser même dans
le travail même d'aider des gens qui te
rend comme une question que les
organisations tactile sans essayer de
provoquer ou de deux quais des fois des
controverses uniquement pour attirer
l'attention des médias
alors on va vous avez écrit votre
chronique et autochtone dans l'immédiat
puis justement on a eu un commentaire
suite à cette chronique là qui en fait
explique un peu ce que vous venez de
dire elle s'appelle docteur miriam balle
elle dit qu'elle a lu votre article
elle dit qu'elle est une alliée de
toujours avec la cause autochtone dès le
départ ça aide beaucoup a dit j'ai fait
une présentation une conférence l'an
dernier suite à un constat que je
faisais depuis plusieurs années en
regardant les pages de radio-canada et
si bicici un drame arrivait chez les
premières nations et il n'y avait aucun
commentaire est certain que j'ai pu
faire n'était pas publiés par contre si
le gouvernement leur donner un peu
d'argent
il y avait beaucoup de commentaires
racistes et négatifs pour moi l'absence
de commentaires étaient une preuve de
racisme
alors donc dès que ça devienne positive
pour les autres
tonnes on les critique de toute manière
mais enfin c'est comme si c'est
extraordinaire quand c'est positif
puis aussi gelé vécu personnellement
c'est comme on est on est aimable sur un
portrait négatif que quand qu'une
personne autochtone une femme en plus
qui fait carrière qui est politicienne
ou un guichet fouet que c'est positif
c'est comme si c'est extraordinaire puis
on en a des femmes qui sont
extraordinaires à les communautés mais
c'est comme c'est tellement peu
médiatisé que quand on est jeune c'est
comme moi c'est en commun vous trouvez
qu'on respecte plus les hommes
autochtones que les femmes autochtones
dans la sphère médiatique
j'ai toujours quasiment verrouillé le
jeu prend pendant ce délai serait les
dernières années en tout cas quelle
commission denquête l'image la femme
autochtone en a pris un coup c'est pas
ce pas positif puisqu'ils étaient mis
sur le débat public ce test est souvent
lire oui je pense que entre les
dernières il ya des pélagiques sont
fortes sont tenaces
et un des projets les plus fous je
pensais que les autochtones sont des
privilégiés de la société donc qui ne
bénéficient de beaucoup de privilèges et
quand le tour ne contribue pas à la
société sas et je pense est le plus
grand peut juger qu'existe environnement
a perdu on l'a vu beaucoup au coes que
suivi aucun demain mais en commun et je
pense que c'est pour ça que même quand
on parle de belles histoires débiles de
belles actions ou d'aider les jeunes ne
réagissent pas positivement parce que
disait voilà encore des préjugés voler
encore des désavantages des privilèges
ils sont a converti la ceni se façonner
ses lignes complètes de fait complet
depuis la tulle le gouvernement du
québec puis gouvernement du canada aussi
mais si on parle du québec ont manqué à
ses responsabilités de sensibiliser la
population québécoise à cette question
de puits auca ya jamais eu de véritables
campagnes d'information de
sensibilisation des québécois sur la
réalité des autochtones
on met des millions pour produire des
millions de dollars en campagne de
promotion de toutes sortes que ce soit
l'utilisation du cellulaire au volant
justement la violence ou tout autre
problématique c'est un problème énorme
actuellement qu'on ne règle pas c'est un
peu comme pour l'environnement pour les
dossiers environnementaux c'est à dire
que si on les traite pas maintenant on
repoussent à plus tard des enjeux qui
vont que ça croit davantage
il ya des problèmes à régler puis d'un
comptable c'est un peu comme un cercle
vicieux aussi tant et aussi longtemps
que la population n'est pas sensibilisés
ben elle sera pas ouverte à ce que les
gouvernements prennent des décisions
parfois difficiles à vendre pour avec
des situations
oui parce que la crise aux cassettes et
javan
ça va faire 29 ans cet automne est ce
que les générations qui arrivent ont une
opinion différente des autochtones
est-ce qu'il ne relève que ce que leurs
parents leur disent leur environnement
parce qu'à l'école bon on a essayé de
changer les livres d'histoire on essaie
de faire évoluer les choses
vous trouvez pas qu'il ya une ouverture
plus grande de la part des jeunes
mais moi je parle de mon coach personnel
avec la situation j'ai des camps que
l'alim son enquête dévoilée le phénomène
qui elle-même qui est hervé avec la
commission vie par la suite j'étais
surprise et non surprise d'un sens que
mes enfants ce qui me rapportait de
l'école c'est exactement les mêmes les
mêmes choses que j'avais entendu lors de
la crise d'oka puis je me dis ça a peu
évolué et puis c'est vrai ce cas-ci
cantonales dit que le gouvernement je
pense qu'elle faillit là dedans parce
que on a une commission royale qui est
que suivi souris mais je comprends pas
qu'ils payent de deux campagnes de
sensibilisation tout ça parce que l'idée
c'est de refaire les liens entre
autochtones et non autochtones rôle est
de démystifier un stéréotype et prégent
et 2015 la même chose c'est triste c'est
il ya peu une grande évolution mais les
jeunes je pense qu'ils ont une ouverture
au monde qui naturel aujourd'hui dans la
notte pas puis ça me donne l'espoir
c'est avec la commission vient
j'ai perçu dans la vie de mes enfants
qu'il y avait personne jusqu'à lui qui
avait fait de coke et autochtone ou pas
puis ccc look sac les questions ayant
sont arrivés mais avant c'était comme si
tu avais été de noter qu'il n'y a aucun
problème c'est que ce serait sa bo en
même temps mais on était confronté notre
crise bancaire mais ça s'améliore et je
le vois comme un temps que j'en sais je
vois chez les étudiants
une amélioration la prise de conscience
des enjeux qui concernent les
autochtones de la même nature parce que
les enjeux environnementaux
oui on le voit chez les jeunes sont
beaucoup plus sensibles et sensibiliser
aux enjeux environnementaux
même chose pour les autochtones alors de
nos jours l'information circule d'un
million de manière dont on peut ouvrir
un journal on peut écouter la télé la
radio mais beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux l'information circule est-ce que
ça ce n'est pas un frein déjà allé
chercher une information diversifiée
donc se renseigner sur plein de sujets
dont celui des autochtones parce que ce
qui arrive aussi sexy un sujet
particulier nous intéresse mais on va se
pencher sur ce sujet à ne pas voir d
autres réalités qui entourent qui nous
attend dans notre société
est ce que ça peut être un frein cette
ouverture en fait sur les enjeux
autochtones quel qu'il soit mais je
trouve que souvent ce qu'on lisse et des
rappels à des stéréotypes par exemple
j'ai fait une chronique sur
l'appropriation d'identité culturelle
dans la fonction publique pour avoir des
emplois mais là dedans j'ai lu pourquoi
les autochtones encore les privilèges
pour des jobs jeu dénonçaient des
fraudes en ré c'est ce qui ressortait
fait souvent vaut lire des destins genre
de commentaire là mais il ya des gens
qui répondent il ya des autochtones qui
répliqua s'appuie moi je trouve ça bien
parce que c'est comme une tribune un peu
peau jeter un débat c'est le lieu d'un
débat avec des fois ça peut être positif
des fois ça dérape
mais je pense que ça peut être positif
pas ça donne une voix
oui mais oui oui la personne va
sélectionner dame inverse faire par son
choix de documentation oui il ya les
deux s'essaye aux lignes de côtés de la
même médaille
les réseaux sociaux si c'est ce que ça
apporte sa porte du plus beau
plus donc on voit les deux mais on
parlait tout à l'heure de d'événements
positifs qui ne sont pas retenus par les
médias traditionnels les médias sociaux
servent beaucoup à sa fin et même +6 et
des belles histoires
je siège sur l'organisme points -2
meshkini la fondation du docteur cette
année voilà donc on utilise beaucoup les
médias sociaux pour justement faire
connaître les belles histoires qui se
passent dans les communautés parce que
on a beau les dg des communiqués de
presse
on peut pas quelles sont les relations
entre les journalistes et par exemple
les communautés des conseils de bande ou
les communautés en général parce que je
le disais il ya aussi la difficulté que
les journalistes ne se déplacent de
moins en moins en fait donc ne vont plus
dans les communautés mais s'ils ont
envie d'aller dans les communautés
découvrir ce qu'il s'y passe
est ce que est ce qu'ils vont être bien
accueilli parce qu'on sait depuis la
crise d'oka encore là il ya beaucoup de
communautés qui se sont repliés qui ont
envie et envie de voir des journalistes
est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est différent
moi je pense que chaque média peut faire
son propre chemin je reviens avec
l'exemple l'abitibi sont souvent bien
accueillis par ce qu'ils font un travail
respectueux oui ces objectifs et là vous
parlez de tous les médias n'ont trouvé
en abitibi parle de raids au canada
parce qu'elle sait où encore canada
c'est l'exemple site là ça dépend des
médias puis ça dépend des régions ça
défend les communautés mais le la plus
je me rappelle il ya quelques années le
conseil de pessamit
oui v
si on n'a qu'à demander aux médias qui
faisaient des reportages ont reçu un
contenu qui vous le souhaitez aller dans
la communauté de faire des reportages
d'obtenir une accréditation au préalable
responsable des communications conseil
et ça a été sud de façon très négative
par les médias comme s'ils vont le
conseil voulait fermer les portes de la
communauté aux médias mais en fait le
conseil répondait une problématique ou
bon quand c'est des médias régionaux
c'est moins pire parce qu'ils
connaissent la communauté connaissent
des gens et savent à qui s'adresser et
ils savent aussi respecter le statut du
chef et du conseil qui sont des
gouvernements locaux tandis que d'autres
médias puis à l'époque il y avait une
crise aussi entre la communauté le
conseil est une entreprise forestière
entre autres et les gouvernements donc
les couvertures saclay beaucoup de
tension et les journalistes donc élevées
dans la communauté
il ne se souciait pas de lot l'autorité
politique locale et les rend compte et
faire des entrevues bon avec les
citoyens qui doivent rencontrer et
rapporter ensuite et le scond une des
horreurs qu'on voit régulièrement c'est
qu'on a porté le propos d'un citoyen de
paix se mettre par exemple en disant les
innus de pessamit les enfants si c'était
l'opinion d'un citoyen suédois pas tenir
compte du fait que ben oui à des
divisions et c'est comme si quand y
avait des divisions dans une communauté
abel de ccc lâche quand ça va mal si des
conflits
c'est tout à fait normal dans n'importe
quelle commune de position il ya des
conflits
s'allumant on a reçu une question de
questions de marcus puisque des automnes
compte pour un très faible pourcentage
la population du québec peut-on vraiment
parler de sous représentativité dans le
milieu journalistique j'imagine dans les
médias au niveau des seins emplois au
niveau
sûrement j'imagine que monsieur parle
oui peut-être justement de là
2 c'est peut-être jeune autochtone qui
voudraient se lancer dans le monde des
médias boudal traitement moi ce que je
confesse que journaliste il est membre
et chemise en même temps en terme de
population c'est sûr que si on applique
6 1% de la population québécoise
mais ils ont pas 1% la couverture
journalistique
j'ai pas vu les derniers chiffres
l'harmonie dans l'être 0,2 pour cent
donc on est encore loin du 1% déjà si on
avait donc oui à la réponse est oui
c'est encore sur la maison d'activités
c'est déjà on atteignait là pour ça ça
c'est déjà très bien
puis mais au delà de ça c'est que c'est
des sujets qui concernent la société il
ya des enjeux de société aussi
et ce n'est pas que des enjeux de deux
communautés autochtones
oui ça concerne la société chinoise suit
d'intérêt public puissent eux-mêmes
d'intérêt public de connaître mieux de
mieux faire connaître à la population
cubaine moins de 400 tonnes alors des
journalistes autochtone dans les médias
il y en a très peu ils ont pas
nécessairement justement envie de
couvrir des enjeux autochtone est plutôt
ne pas de parler de la société en
général ce qu'on voit c'est des
chroniqueurs de plus en plus il y avoue
cindy mais il ya aussi isabelle picard
un qui travaille pour
pour le journal la presse il ya michel
jean qui est à tva
il y en a quelques-uns mais avez vous
l'impression que les jeunes ont envie de
se lancer en journalisme à ce que c'est
un métier intéressant je préparais pense
ça soit parce que je suis allé à un
moment donné au collège ki moon a
rencontré des jeunes leur dire hey il ya
de la relève la monotone ya des portes
sont ouvertes on attendait des jeunes de
chez vous pour devenir journaliste est
ce qu'on m'avait répondu
et là c'était une personne n'était pas
tout le monde mais non ce n'est pas un
métier qui nous intéresse parce que
c'est toujours négatif parce que les
nouvelles l'information au départ c'est
négatif
c'est vrai que c'est pas évident quand
on se retrouve confronté à 110 bas je
vais juste parler des mauvaises
nouvelles puis de ce qui se passe mal ce
qui n'est pas le cas non plus
parce que justement il ya une diversité
de sujets et puis on est capable de
parler de will we do ce qui se passe
mais de ce qui se fait de bien et de ce
qui ressort
et puis les résultats que ça peut donner
et on le seuil des reportages qui ont
été faits qui ont changé la donne sur
certaines politiques et sociales même
qui est des enquêtes qui ont été
ouvertes ce tas des reportages et tout
ça donc c'est oui c'est peut-être
négatif de façon générale mais il ya des
retombées positives quoi faudrait le
voir comme ça je pense qu'il ya un état
mais surtout cheikhouna ou dans d'autres
programmes dédiés aux autochtones cd je
crois que c'est des jeunes qui veulent
donner à leur communauté
oui donc l'idée d'aller en communication
c'est plus pour rôle en communication
dans leur communauté ou pour des médias
autochtone oui allez travailler pour des
médias québécois pour parler aux
québécois un enfant c'est pas les mêmes
c'est pas les mêmes messages sont pas
les mêmes en scène de la sport aux
autochtones la même façon qu'on
s'adresse aux québécois sur le sujet le
même sujet donc ce que je peux
comprendre que des jeunes autochtones
soient moins intéressés aller dans les
grands médias québécois
on parle beaucoup du québec mais est ce
que pour l'ensemble du canada ce que la
couverture médiatique des enjeux
autochtones est différent dans les
médias ailleurs au pays donc les médias
anglophones videmment principalement là
mais moi j'aime bien mais si je trouve
ça super et un sens elle le fait
s'appelle kristen guy christ oui en fait
une sociologue doctorante elle a fait
ses recherches sur des femmes
autochtones à le précise femmes
autochtones 3 ce samedi trois tonnes 3
non autochtone des blanches puis a dit
qu'il correspondait au stéréotype de la
femme peur dans le fond c'était pour
éliminer les préjugés donc dans ces six
femmes le lait les six étaient proches
de leur famille avait aucune de ces
femmes qui consommaient se droguer ou se
prostituer qui ce qu'elle est
ce qu'elle a découvert c'est que ces
femmes les femmes blanches avaient fait
l'objet de six fois plus de reportages
accompagnées généralement de grandes
photos qui se retrouvait à la csu
d'alors de saint louis qui toute la
sympathie médiatique était vraiment pour
les femmes qui est un non autochtone
puis aussi dans la moyenne
la fsp quatre fois plus petit pour les
autochtones les espaces occupés inhalé
le portable donc à pitti et c'est tout
documenter puis je trouvais ce comme
très intéressant parce que ça illustre
est vraiment dans l'ouest canadien un
traitement est notre de ce que je
comprends oui si vous l'avez laissé mais
basée sur une recherche vraiment un
scientifique finalement fait que je
trouve ça intéressant
voyons voyons voix sensiblement la même
chose ailleurs
mais au québec on voit une différence
entre la couverture des médias
anglophones la couverture de musique
francophone sont l'observent ok il ya
une distinction
qu'est ce qu'on constate moi ce cache en
fait mon hypothèse c'est pour les médias
francophones c'est bon ce sont des
québécois francophones qui voit dans
chez les autochtones en fait des
adversaires au niveau de l'occupation
territoriale
ça se joue beaucoup dans dans l'opinion
qu'ont les québécois à l'égard des
autochtones au québec c'est vraiment
particulier parce qu'au québec
à part les cris et les inuits et les
naskapis ya jamais eu de traiter de
cession compartiments du canada
donc la question territoriale est
fondamental est au centre
les grandes qui sont politiques et les
autochtones c'est lié aux territoires
encore aujourd'hui mais bon comme il y
en eu plein d'autres artistes
et ça je crois que sa teinte l'opinion
qu'ont les québécois en général les dons
des vies d'amendé
journaliste québécois aussi au niveau
des médias anglophones donc ce que je
vois chez les québécois anglophones il
ya moins cette télé réalité là en sur la
question c'est toi je pense moi ce que
j'ai dit c'est qu'une compétition des
nationalismes en fait le québécois
nationalistes ce sans compétition
lorsqu'il voit des autochtones qui sont
nationaux il est là pour leur propre
leurs besoins jusque là le schème de
pensée je pense de deux des médias
anglophones mais c'est un chant plus
canadien donc c'est plus donc on voit
moins en moins ce sentiment d'être en
compétition sur un nationalisme nos
territoriales oui on a une autre
question qui est arrivé à ce que le
problème de représentativité résidera
dans la façon que les autochtones ont de
diffuser leurs nouvelles donc réseaux
sociaux plutôt que médias conventionnels
oui mais c'est pas dans la façon que les
autres acteurs ont diffusé leur nouvelle
en fait c'est pour les autres
choisissent la façon de diffuser la
nouvelle mais la façon dont la nouvelle
diffusée oui ça joue c'est que là on le
dit antoine dans les médias
traditionnels
c'est plus difficile mais mais derrière
cette question là il y en a quand même
une qui est tout à fait pertinente ou
moins bien constater que beaucoup
d'organisations manque de conseils mais
je travaille beaucoup avec les
conservant les chefs les conseils où on
ne fait pas on ne souhaite pas
nécessairement communiqué certaines
informations certaines nouvelles
oui oui moi aussi je les remercie les
remarqués et pourquoi pas que ce soit
mal interprété mal ce qui les lie pour
certaines nouvelles ou pour certains
certains certaines autorités le le
message est en fait non le le secteur du
message en fait
[Musique]
c'est pas la population québécoise
en fait on a même du mal à lyon on s'en
fout de ce que les attaquants vont
penser
nous ce qui nous préoccupe c'est notre
population
si notre communauté c'est notre nation
c'est possible de ce que les québécois
vont penser oui non les couper et demain
c'est ici par l'expérience aussi de voir
que même si certaines nouvelles on pense
que ça va
une bonne nouvelle dès fois ci dessus
négativement ou c'est mal interprété ou
c'est mal diffusée ou c'est pas
difficile du tout donc l'effort investi
pour communiquer de nouvelles
certains se disent à vous même pas la
peine donc concentrons nous sur ceux à
qui on veut véritablement parler c'est à
dire nos commettants nos citoyens et le
public québécois ben si la peine
d'attendre là c'est en même temps
c'était réparé chacun reste cantonné
chez lui on crée des murs de la cage une
hausse possible le cas jouer ou non à
vic
je voulais partir un programme de voir
qu'il avait persuadés à gaza pendant
quelques années et dans les médias il y
avait eu une très belle couverture dans
les médias québécois
oui on avait parlé abondamment de lui de
son programme au nunavik sont une
journée le gouvernement du nunavut a
décidé de ne plus financer son programme
c'est exact pour twitter de raison qui
est qui soutenu par des études par une
analyse plus une décision objective et
ont décidé de financer un autre
programme n'était pas celui de jouer
chez nous oui ils ont communiqué la
nouvelle alors communauté à leur nation
et ça a été ça a été bien traité par les
médias locaux
et ça a été la réaction a été
relativement correct ou s'il ya des gens
qui étaient déçus de la décision mais il
ya plus de sept points scandale cette
fois ni action très très forte négative
alors épidermique alors que dans les
médias québécois c'était tout le
contraire ça a été vu
comme quelque chose de scandaleux et
puis moi j'avais suggéré au gouvernement
du nunavik société makivik de réagir
d'allied au devant des médias de
l'expliquer la réaction c'est à dire non
ça change rien nous c'est les i nous et
qui sont qui sont cochés paris concernés
sont touchés par la décision
nous sommes devant des populations on le
fait on n'a pas convaincre les québécois
qu'est ce qu'on a fait oui une bonne
décision
oui moi je pense que c'est une erreur je
pense qu'au contraire ils doivent tenir
compte de l'opinion que les québécois on
est une erreur si on devrait tenir
compte
ben oui moi je suis pour la
communication oui si je suis ici
aujourd'hui puis j'ai fait une chronique
là tu sais que à quelque part j'aimerais
qu'ils aient un traitement plus juste de
la situation des autochtones en général
dans les médias mais mais en même temps
je me demande si la réaction du
gouvernement makivik à ce moment là
c'était pas comme d'être là d'avoir à
s'expliquer parce que de toute façon et
on rompt pas la sympathie qu'il
méconnaît cette décision et je sais pas
je la constate m
je ne juge pas je la comprends mais ça
devient une question de justement de la
source et de jusqu'où on n'est pas
investir du temps des ressources et de
subir d'une certaine façon le regard des
médias québécois alors qu'on dit à la
fin ben à la fin de la journée commence
en anglais là ça changera peut-être
n'ont-ils vient de toute façon et pour
nous ça change véritablement rien que la
population soit compte notre décision
donc si j'ai comme sa maman place et ça
c'est si on regarde de façon plus
globale
c'est important je trouve que justement
les autochtones ne répondent pas à ces à
des articles qui sont faut qu'ils sont
erronés ou en voie d agir beaucoup plus
on devait corriger les informations
je trouve que c'est important comptant
deux parce qu'on le dit le gouvernement
a failli à sa tâche d'informer
sensibiliser la population québécoise
c'est les médecins qui le font oui mais
donc je pense parce qu'il ya pas
longtemps à l'automne j'ai réagi j'ai vu
un article dans une revue qui est bien
connu et qui travaille très bien en
passant que je lis moi même et l'article
traitait des femmes en général non
autochtone des femmes violences
le taux de colère thébaux au préfet d
des femmes problématique
oui la photo choisie c'est la photo
d'une jeune attikameks très jolie que
j'avais déjà vu je me suis mis à faire
des recherches ou j'ai vu cette photo là
et c'était dans un document qui avait
été produit par femme autochtone et
condition féminine autochtones à
l'époque cherche la jeune fille puisse
avoir donné son autorisation pour
associer la musique est non et ça
faisait comme je pense qu'elle avait 14
ans et puis aujourd'hui dans vingtaine
la jeune fille a jamais rien fait moi
j'écris est ce test cette revue lowy
alors conseillé d'enlever jeu ça fait
marges du fait des mauvaises association
parce qu'on parle de violence faut
forcément vous mettiez à l'image encore
d'une jeune fille autochtone gisèle
l'art et ses étés on sait que ça paraît
pas toujours mais dans ce colosse ça
paraissait une réponse on me référer à
la condition féminine parce qu'on m'a
dit c'était une photo qui appartenait je
vais pas fouiller plus loin et moi je
pense journalistes non plus mais je sais
pas c'est comme j'ai pas j'ai pas senti
comme un besoin de comprendre la
réaction oui et puis c'est juste comme
madame tout le monde le cuivre les
choses réagi pic qui questionnait d'un
petit louis
c'est vrai je trouve que de façon
générale les autochtones ne répondent
pas assez souvent jouait sur d'affaires
l'immédiat des fois puis il ya peu de
commentaires passés en tout cas mais en
même temps je me demande si justement
c'est pas parce qu'on est un peu ternie
des coups d'épée dans la lute alors leur
tournée en une question de questions de
myrna ai dit comment les journalistes
peuvent-ils traiter les sujets liés à la
violence ou au crime dans une communauté
autochtone de façon responsable sans
perpétuer les stéréotypes
ça va être notre dernière question parce
que l'heure tourne mais on va y répondre
- 3 j'aurais tendance à dire que ce
journal est ce la faute des jeux qui
avait consulté les personnes qui sont
impliquées dans la communauté
intervenants sociaux police faut passer
par les gens la communauté pour savoir
ce qu'on en dise qu'ils veulent dans des
puits la façon qui explique la situation
de questions ça serait mon conseil
oui c'est vraiment de les chercher de
l'aide des experts
justement ce soit de la commission de
santé services sociaux des premières
nations
il ya des ressources et de l'information
qui existent tout est là puis à chaque
au moins deux fois par année on voit
dans les grands médias québécois dé
traiter de sujets de violence pauvreté
au nunavik chez les inuits
c'est fréquent et moi je suis convaincu
que les journalistes ou les chercheurs
les personnes qui dormaient sur ce
reportage de delphine causes utiles à la
société parce qu'on témoigne des
difficultés que vivent des autochtones
ont fait de la population québécoise et
canadienne mais ce projet ça on perpétue
justement des p jugé alors que 6 et
devait être accompagné les textes oui on
peut apporter d'une situation
problématique de violence ou out
mais que ce soit compagnie aussi
d'éléments contextuels explicatifs pour
que les lecteurs comprennent qu'on ne
peut pas faire c'est une situation
particulière des raisons pour lesquelles
les situations wales journaliste doit
faire ses devoirs parce que le lecteur
ne les fera pas après ne fera pas cette
recherche pour justement contextualiser
la problématique traitée dans tel ou tel
article n'a alors en conclusion qu'est
ce qu'il faudrait faire aujourd'hui pour
attirer par exemple des jeunes
autochtones en journalisme et qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour que justement
les journalistes non autochtone soient
plus ouverts la réalité autochtone plus
curieux et enlèvent leurs oeillères s'il
y en a ou laisse tomber les préjugés
s'il y en a mais les phares de
contextualisations on en parle depuis
début mai
mission g j'espère que c'est un message
qui peut être retenu
l'autre chose c'est qu'on va avoir de
rapport dans lequel tu de commissions
importantes cette année donc j'espère
donc très bientôt louis oui tpe aussi
une fois depuis lyon lyon rélevé entre
autres que les médias jouent est pas
vraiment un rôle positif dans leur
mandat entre couperet faire une histoire
courte ce que je veux dire c'est que
j'espère qu'il va avoir un travail de
sensibilisation sur ce qui va ressortir
de ces deux rapports le oui parce que il
faudrait pas encore dans 29 ans qu'on
soit devant notre crise puis qu'on
répète encore les mêmes préjugés et
stéréotypes
donc ce serait un peu c'était la
conclusion de votre chronique aussi un
lieu d'être de laisser-faire l'ignorance
l'anair d'ouvrir grands pour comprendre
la réalité bien sûr tellement de façons
d'aller chercher de l'information
aujourd'hui je suis je m'explique mal
qu'un journaliste ou quelqu'un qui
traînent dans les médias ne fassent pas
cet effort a l'audace et de comprendre
un peu plus en tout cas je comprends la
notion du temps là mais quand même il ya
de l'information facile à accéder sur
internet les gens sont ouverts souvent
souvent chaussures que ça vous arrive
aussi les gens nous questionnent dans
nos nos spécialités un peu puis ça nous
fait plaisir de répondre oui mais
ricardo dit oui c'est le concept de
réconciliation que doit être appliquée
par tout d'abord par les gouvernements
effectivement une fois que les
commissions m'envoie rendu public le
rapport d'important que les
gouvernements et les peines des intègre
et les mettre en oeuvre
en tenant compte du fait que comme je le
disais en introduction que la façon dont
les médiathèques les enjeux autochtones
a une importance très grand donc ça
prend des mesures
et je pense et le thème réconciliation
radio-canada a fait sienne l'appel à
l'action
la commission vérité et réconciliation
tous les méthodes de belfort puis ça ça
veut dire que pour bien couvrir un
enjeux autochtones ou des sujets tels
cas ne suffit pas d'embaucher une
autochtone ou un autochtone et des
rebelles nous faisons notre part donc se
pose beaucoup plus que ça c'est du wild
merci beaucoup et rivières dinars merci
à tous les deux si vous avez envie de
continuer à réagir à l'isie aller sur la
page facebook de l'espace autochtone ou
encore sur notre site internet et
allaient continuer cette conversation
merci à tous merci beaucoup on se donne
rendez vous vendredi prochain à 12h15 au
revoir
[Musique]
oh
non